[Music]
well I don't know if you know but there
is gonna be a wedding which ones on
suits now do you think their suits
creators they had anything to do with
like obviously you were planning for
many seasons to be engaged and get
married on the show but here we are this
like timing of its final season and her
wedding yet you didn't make it that on
purpose so like buzz it up oh I have no
idea why they do what they do but I
think it's you know synchronicity no
matter what yeah it's pretty special
that was something company in real life
at the same time it's happening on the
show obviously you have to be happy for
Megan I know you guys are close big
wedding on the way have you given her
any a marriage advice or advice for her
big day oh god like it doesn't need any
advice no I don't think we did well I
don't think we knew that any of that was
happening the last time we saw Megan
practice all of it so are you fascinated
shopping will you guys be over in London
what is faster what is the fact that
it's the Hat I have my fascinator and a
glam borrow yours oh yeah if you get
into anyone I know my mom has tons of
hats and gloves okay so if you go so I
wouldn't just need to knock on my mom's
door she's got everything I need if she
gets a fast tail yeah yeah then you need
the curtsy curtsy you got it now what
will you get them as a royal cutting
couple if you go to the wedding or not
will you send like a toaster you're
trying to choose between like a blender
breadmaker you know if it's something
classy like a Vitamix she's gonna need a
Vitamix yeah
and Harry the rumors have it Harry has
been getting into like great shape and
he it seriously yeah so if I to mix is
it okay if I'm the best there's so many
things we don't know are we going to the
Royal Wedding we don't know it is Megan
Marvel getting a Vitamix from Patrick
that you know et spoke with Patrick Jay
Adams and his wife actress director
Troian Bellisario at an event for this
bar saves lives a company that supports
child hunger around the world I just
think you just so rarely get an
opportunity to do something where you're
part of a really cool product that also
does something fantastic and something
that has such a powerful effect on kids
all over the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]